mon directement le bento ancien juriste
et co créatrice de l'application urgence
violences policières
bonjour à ma la bndes si merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
alors qu'on me rappelle une
manifestation pour dénoncer entre autres
la loi sécurité globale certains de ces
articles sont jugées liberticides
inquiétant des rapporteurs de l'onu ont
même demandé à la france de revoir sa
copie expliquez nous pourquoi réécrire
cette loi ou l'abandonner définitivement
serait une nécessité pour la france
alors sur la loi sur la sécurité de
l'eau balle ce n'est pas seulement
l'article 24 qui pose problème c'est
l'ensemble des articles de la loi sur la
sécurité globale qui portent atteinte à
nos libertés individuelles est
fondamentale au-delà de cette loi sur la
liberté sécurité globale il faut aussi
le rappeler la loi sur le séparatisme
qui est du même acabit que cette loi sur
la sécurité globale
donc on le voit bien depuis depuis
quelques années déjà à chaque fois qu'il
ya des faits exceptionnels les
parlementaires essaient de légiférer
pour restreindre nos droits les plus
fondamentaux qu'on l'a vu la semaine
dernière avec cette manifestation qui
n'était pas du tout violente où on a
interpellé où il ya eu de multiples
interpellations arbitraires
donc c'est juste un pas en avant vers
l'autoritarisme et de plus en plus de
plus les années passent et plus on se
rend compte que les parlementaires sont
prêts à sacrifier nos libertés au profit
de leur propre sécurité
si je puisse si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
donc oui quand on voit ces jeunes femmes
qui ont été interpellés je pense à moon
avec son parapluie
on a essayé de trouver des motifs
fallacieux comme comme ouvrir son
parapluie serait un signe de départ de
violence de la part des blacks blocs ces
justes tout à fait ridicule
donc oui il faut qu'on soit dans la rue
aujourd'hui
les mobilisations faut qu'elle continue
et nous on appellera à se mobiliser
aussi des dès le début du mois de
janvier
et je tiens à vous rappeler qu' il faut
vraiment qu'on fasse une convergence que
ce soit les les mouvements sociaux ou
les quartiers populaires qui sont visés
aussi aujourd'hui j'ai une pensée pour
la famille de 2 du jeune de degas camara
qui a perdu la vie le 17 janvier 2018 et
la justice n'a rien d'autre à proposer
qu'un non lieu
donc c'est 20 vers un non lieu et
aujourd'hui ils manifestaient à champs
sur marne et c'était important de
rappeler aussi tous et non lieu à
répétition tout c'est non condamnation
de certains policiers et qui demande
encore plus de d'impunité puisque va on
le voit avec l'article 24
on le voit avec la surveillance de masse
on le voit avec la loi sur le
séparatisme donc qui aujourd'hui vise
une seule et même communauté mais qui à
l'avenir visera tout le monde puisque
tous ceux qui seront contre ce
gouvernement seront considérés comme des
potentiels terroristes ou musulmans
puisque aujourd'hui on essaye de ça on
fait la malle gamme sur sur la
communauté musulmane et ça c'est très
dangereux
donc si on n'y prend pas garde c'est
beaucoup de nos droits qui vont être
qu'ils vont être bafouée donc c'est très
bien que les gens s'organisent de façon
autonome et épices aller dans la rue
pour créer ce rapport de force
non vous êtes co créatrice de
l'application urgence violences
policières
de quel constat faites-vous partie pour
créer cette application
alors nous on est parti du constat que
dans toutes les affaires le processus il
est identique à chaque fois les caméras
de télésurveillance ne fonctionne pas
dès lors que des policiers sont sont mis
en cause dans des violences
dans un meurtre donc à chaque fois
systématiquement les caméras ne
fonctionne pas après on nous a parlé de
caméras piétons les caméras piétons il
faut peut-être aussi se poser la
question quand est-ce qu'elle va être
actionnés elles vont être actionné au
bon vouloir du policier donc imaginez
vous dans la sphère de michel est claire
je me doute que les policiers auraient
pu enclencher leur caméra piétons donc
voila et donc et du coup le le herriot
paraît qui n'est jamais apparence est
toujours une source de conflits à chaque
fois qu'on le demande
donc on part de ce constat que les
policiers depuis des années depuis des
décennies ne veulent pas être contrôlée
c'est à dire qu' il ne supporte pas
l'institution policière ne veut pas se
remettre en question ça il faut il faut
en tenir compte et c'est très important
de le dire
la preuve en est c'est que vous avez vu
tout la multiplication de toutes ces
manifestations sauvages illégales de la
part de certains policiers et c'est très
important de dire qu'aujourd'hui nous on
s'est organisé de façon citoyenne et on
veut un contrôle citoyen plus que les
pouvoirs publics nous propose rien nous
on s'est organisé de façon à avoir un
outil qui puisse permettre à n'importe
quel individu à n'importe quel citoyen
qui assiste ou qui seraient qui seraient
victimes de violences policières de
sortir ce portable est de dire voilà
vous êtes filmés avec l'application uvp
il ya une copie qui est envoyé en même
temps sur nos serveurs il ya une copie
qui est conservé et ça nous on en a la
preuve puisque on l'a bien vu le constat
qu'on fait depuis toutes ces vidéos
c'est que les gens nous disent à chaque
fois que les policiers entendent parler
de l'application uvp on sent qu'ils à
une désescalade de la violence et leurs
comportements changent et que les
poursuites qui devait être faite à leur
encontre pour outrage et rébellion
ils sont hésitants et du coup ça ça
change la donne et c'est très important
parce que quand ya pas de preuve
c'est difficile de contredire la version
policière parce que souvent les gens qui
filme souvent les gens qui sont témoins
sont amenés à être poursuivi pour
outrage et rébellion
donc du coup on s'est organisé de façon
citoyenne de façon à ce que les gens
puissent se saisir de cette arme
si je peux me permettre de parler c'est
notre seule arme face à ces policiers
qui on le voit bien ne se remettent
jamais en question et c'est difficile
même quand il ya des images c'est très
compliqué parce qu'on lui demande le
contexte avant et après par contre quand
il s'agit quand il s'agit de violences à
l'encontre des policiers là on ne
demande pas le contexte
donc voilà donc c'est toujours la même
histoire et donc du coup nous on veut
imposer cette surveillance citoyenne et
on l'a bien vu ce que cette loi célérité
globale qui a été si tu es en réponse à
cette application
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
juriste et co créatrice de l'application
purge ans violences policières merci à
vous